so you never want to give your baby
apple juice in fact you don't want to
give your kids juice so recently I read
an article related to a recommendation
by a pediatric group so this is what
they said
fruit juice has no essential role in
healthy balanced diets of children okay
no essential role that's their statement
what are they missing
they're missing the fact that fruit
juice has the same amount of sugar as
soda that fruit juice is basically a
pasteurized dead product pasteurization
which involves heating destroys enzymes
and destroys nutrition in fact when you
consume that much concentrated sugar
without the fiber with other
phytonutrients without the nutrition
you're gonna create vitamin deficiencies
and on top of that children between the
ages of 2 and 18 consume 50% of their
fruit as juice so when a group of
doctors who are supposed to be experts
in childhood care make a statement like
this it really tells you how little they
know about the relationship between
sugar and insulin and creating all sorts
of problems down the road so the worst
thing you can do is feed your baby's
fruit juice okay because they're they're
just developing and giving them pure
sugar is just gonna set them up for
diabetes and the same thing goes for
other children you do not want to give
your children liquid fruit all right
thanks for watching if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos